who would have thought that it could
come to this Facebook begging
governments to tame the wild wild web to
police censor and control it to think it
all began
oh so innocently people want to go on
the internet and check out their friends
so why not build a website that offers
that I'm talking about taking the entire
social experience of college and putting
it online it was so simple then a place
for teenagers to share their
relationship status for friends to share
pictures announce parties keep in touch
but somewhere along the line Facebook
grew dark gathering and selling people's
personal information BOTS fake news
election meddling censorship and
suspensions targeting innocent people at
times and the videos streams mass
murders the New Zealand shooting rapes
snuff videos it seemed Facebook CEO did
nothing but apologize that was a big
mistake
now is a mistake and it was my mistake
and I'm really sorry that this happened
and I'm sorry and I'm sorry for it it
seems Zuckerberg is tired of keeping
Facebook his own platform clean he now
wants governments to do it ministries to
police the net with rules and
regulations
[Music]
the saying goes the road to hell is
paved with good intentions though
something tells me Zuckerberg is less
interested in good intentions and more
concerned about bad press and profit but
hey who knows he talks so pretty by
updating the rules for the internet we
can preserve what's best about it
the freedom for people to express
themselves remarkable he's actually
saying that government censorship
politicians deciding what you can and
cannot do or say will somehow make the
Internet freer when has that ever
happened before in fact one of the
scandals Facebook was embroiled in was
its wholesale cleansing of pages and
news feeds it didn't like Infowars Alex
Jones even for a while Arty's mafic
media all four of mafic spacious
including in the now were taken down for
no reason other than pressure from probe
or think tanks and a lazy report from
CNN the messages are slick filled with
graphics new grabbing dairy graphics
aimed at young left-leaning Americans
getting news from social media and the
videos have been viewed tens of millions
of times billions of times thank you
apparently it's all for you your freedom
your safety so here it is a corporate
billionaire with dirty hands asking
politicians to censor and regulate the
web you don't get 500 million friends
without making a few enemies he once
said but it seems Zuckerberg is heading
towards having just a few friends and
millions of enemies so why is the
question when investigative journalist
Dave Lynde off believes Mark Zuckerberg
is simply looking after his own
interests here wolves are getting closer
of regulation of his company there's a
lot of anger and it's a growing call to
break up Facebook to regulate Facebook
and I think what's everybody doing is
recognizing that something is going to
happen and rather than face it alone he
wants to call for regulation of all his
competitors too because if he's the only
one who's regulated he gets broken up
the company gets smaller has less power
and gets hurt in the competition with
larger entities like Google he's trying
to shape it but I don't think his
argument holds a lot of water that has
that he's been making all along that
somehow Facebook is just a free speech
issue
you